bueno yo quiero invitarlos a que hagamos
el siguiente ejercicio recuerdan cuando
tenían 7 años
bueno entonces saquen su teléfono y les
voy a dar unas instrucciones vamos a
recordar que soñábamos en ese momento
saquen su teléfono
y vamos a abrir el navegador cualquiera
que prefieran por favor alcanzan a ver
esa dirección si no yo se las dictó
tiny de in n y rl punto com
las de de x
no se preocupen que tenemos tiempo aquí
lo más importante es que si a alguno no
le llegará a funcionar porque tiene que
hacer una actualización en su teléfono o
algo lo pueden hacer después del evento
otra vez porque la dirección va a
permanecer en la página de té exmujeres
bogotá
listo
les va a aparecer cuando hagan eso la
cámara de facebook
y apenas les salga van a activar el modo
self y ósea en la camarita se van a
poner hasta que se vean ustedes y les va
a aparecer la nube donde van a escribir
ese sueño que tenían
bien
cuando miren así les aparece una nube y
van a escribir ahí hacen clic y ponen
ese sueño
y luego ponen done para que les aparezca
y luego pueden poner clic en la cámara
para tomar la foto y luego grabarla
si no lo logran ojalá lo logren ahorita
pero si no lo lograrán porque acá
estamos muchos y la capacidad de
procesamiento es bueno pero no estamos
todavía donde el futuro quiere que
estemos bien
y vamos a compartir ese sueño que
teníamos
y lo vamos a tallar con el hashtag de
text mujeres bogotá que es hasta poder
2018 y hashtag per x bm
porque vamos a hablar del poder que
tiene ser capaz de soñar
estos quien ya escribió por ahí su sueño
e
vamos ya empiezo a ver gente tomando en
las fotos
y esto ahora y oigo que hay unos los que
no alcancen lo hacen después y saben que
los quiero invitar a que además inviten
a sus amigos y amigas a escribir sus
sueños
porque yo he de confesar que desde
chiquita he sido muy inerte me fascina
aprender me fascinaba leer estudiar
siempre conversaciones con mi mamá con
mi abuela era una delicia porque me
imaginaba lo que podía llegar a ser
teniendo el conocimiento para cambiar el
mundo
y en vacaciones mi mejor plan era ir a
un colegio que había fundado mi tía en
cali y mi tía rosario como yo y iba a
cali el calendario era opuesto al de mi
colegio normal entonces me ponía el
uniforme de mi prima ello a colegio eso
sonaba un poco raro pues no creo que
todos los niños en vacaciones esperarán
ir a otra vez otro colegio y mi tía me
daba un espacio infinito para seguir
aprendiendo incluso en vacaciones era un
poco rara y un día domingo recibimos una
llamada en esas llamadas y nos avisaba
que mi tía había muerto en un accidente
de carro
no había palabras
la vida nos cambio pero en ese momento a
los 11 años entendí de lo que uno no
hace hoy no puede estar seguro de hacer
que suceda mañana la única manera en que
podemos vivir infinitamente o lo menos
por muchos años es dejar una huella cada
día
yo soñaba con ser presidente pero siendo
leer no era la más popular de todas
tenía muy buenas amigas eso sí pero así
como para levantar votos en una campaña
no era tan fácil en mi casa en cambio
creían mucho en mí mi abuela para el
ejemplo alguna vez para una campaña que
iba a hacer para el consejo estudiantil
me hizo esta pancarta evidentemente no
era la más objetiva como pueden notar
pero de alguna manera me daba el impulso
para seguir hacia adelante pensando que
si iba a ser posible algo de ese estilo
lo que más me gustó cuando hice esa
campaña fue lo interesante que era ser
capaz de imaginarse las necesidades de
aquellas personas que uno iba a
representar y como después porque fui
elegida que conste como iba a ejecutarlo
como respondíamos a eso que era la
promesa que habíamos hecho las reglas de
mi casa de educación no eran muy
tradicionales y por ahí hay gente a la
que le consta que era una casa que
funcionaba un poco diferente mi mamá y
mi abuela mis hermanas teníamos una
dinámica que no era la más típica mi
colegio tampoco era el más tradicional y
todo eso de alguna manera me fue
impulsando voy a darles un ejemplo de
las reglas de funcionamiento de
educación de mi casa mi mamá decía que
todo permiso que yo le pidiera podía
hacerlo con una sola condición si yo
creía que al día siguiente esa noticia
podía salir
en la primera página de un periódico
imagínense lo raro que sonaba cuando a
mis compañeras de colegio las mamas les
trataban de controlar en la adolescencia
los permisos y en cambio mi mamá trataba
de que yo aprendiera autoregulación de
eso ya de por sí era raro
y evidentemente creo que me di menos
permisos de los que le dieron a muchas
de mis amigas
pues empezando mi vida profesional tuve
grandes oportunidades y tuve una
oportunidad preciosa porque pude empezar
trabajando en temas de participación
ciudadana con comunidades y tuve la gran
fortuna de encontrarme con un grupo de
empresarios que querían construir una
visión de país en la que el juego limpio
y la reconstrucción del tejido social de
confianza era la prioridad era el
mostrar que si se puede jugar limpio que
si se puede pensar en el largo plazo y
trabajar en el corto haciendo que las
cosas sucedan y ahí pasé a trabajar en
temas de anti corrupción y bueno también
me dediqué a hacer que las cosas
sucedieran como tenía tanto gusto por
aprender pues tenía el reto de hacer que
las cosas sucedieran realmente y aplicar
rápidamente lo aprendido obviamente esa
primera parte de mi carrera profesional
tuvo otra cosa muy interesante y es que
el eje central era democracia
participativa por lo tanto yo seguía
sintiendo que esa ruta si me llevaría a
ser líder de uno
que había sido mi sueño y que en ese
momento seguía siendo mi sueño
tuve además la fortuna de encontrarme
con unos mentores inmejorables personas
que eran capaces de defender su visión
de país de defender aquello por lo que
trabajaban de generar soluciones en
salud o en ingeniería y entendía el
valor que tiene el tener mentores que no
importa como piensen no importa como
vean el mundo pero que definitivamente
sean ejecutores y tengan la generosidad
para ayudarlo a uno a crecer hoy algunos
ya no están pero aquellos que siguen
vivos me siguen dando valiosos consejos
trabajé
[Aplausos]
trabajé en temas de participación
ciudadana de anti-corrupción de
publicidad política poniendo en el reto
dejar de ser la dirigida como politóloga
trabajen temas con comunidades y luego
la vida me fue retando más cuando en
2006 el país empezó a cambiar decidí
ayudar a aterrizar inversionistas que le
apostaban a nuestro país y eso me
requirió aprender de otras industrias
banca y finanzas infraestructura
operaciones fusiones y adquisiciones
siempre retada por aprender lo cual no
me era muy mucho sacrificio porque me
fascina aprender cómo pueden notar pero
definitivamente retada por entender cómo
liderar equipos cómo construir visiones
comunes entre aquellos equipos y cómo
lograr llevar a cabo la identificación
de esos problemas para poder plantear
estrategias que permitieran llevar a
cabo soluciones reales
hoy en día dado que cada vez me voy
moviendo igual de temas y aún afronte
sigue siendo un reto el cómo lograron
construir una visión común en un equipo
de trabajo para hacer que se ejecute a
la perfección en el día a día y que el
impacto que ésta tiene no deje de
suceder
las mujeres de mi familia siempre han
sido un gran impacto en mi vida y he
tenido un ejemplo de mi mamá de mi
abuela de mis tías de mis dos hermanas
hoy en día también de mi sobrina y todo
esto sumado a los mentores que tuve me
ha enseñado que definir a quien tener en
tu vida es un valor agregado
saber de quién rodearte saber de quién
querer aprender mi coach dice que no
somos perfectos pero somos perfectibles
es decir que todos los días podemos
trabajar por ser mejores y la única
forma de lograrlo es tener aquellos que
te rodean siendo mejores que tú en algo
más alegres más disciplinados más
curiosos mejores personas más generosos
más divertidos y ha sido así como
definitivamente me he mantenido retado
teniendo buscando siempre un poco
obsesivamente personas talentosas pero
también personas con un nivel de
autoexigencia enorme
y es así como a pesar de que yo no me
formé en el mundo de la tecnología
inicialmente
siempre utilice herramientas de
tecnología para solucionar los problemas
que tenía en los trabajos en los que
estaba construimos una red de ciudadanos
y empresarios para trabajar en
participación ciudadana en la
implementación de las herramientas de la
constitución del 91 logramos articular
una red de más de 45 mil colombianos
unidos en la lucha contra la corrupción
y de esa manera empezamos también a
entender patrones cómo usar la
tecnología para entender patrones que
podrían evitar problemas o podrían
evitar corrupción
la vida me fue llevando y en el 2006
cuando el país ya era diferente como les
contaba salía al mundo privado me di a
acompañar empresas que aterrizaban y que
le apostaban a esa colombia que yo
quería y un día me deje conquistar
absolutamente por una empresa de
tecnología y me fui a trabajar con ellos
esta empresa tenía una cosa fascinante y
era la oportunidad que me daba para
sumar talento colombiano a una operación
global que sucedía desde silicon valley
no no me fascine solamente por la
tecnología per se porque la tecnología
sin un uso y sin hacer nada puede
fascinar lo a uno pero lo que realmente
me hizo rendirme a sus pies fue la
capacidad para solucionar problemas a
gran escala la posibilidad de
multiplicar las soluciones que teníamos
en lugares pequeños para aplicarlas en
otros lugares del planeta donde esos
problemas podían suceder de manera fin
y definitivamente
me fui metiendo en este mundo con una
pregunta muy importante y es las
tecnologías están cambiando y nos están
haciendo cambiar nuestra interacción con
las máquinas es inevitable yo no creo
que nos vayan a reemplazar las máquinas
creo que vamos a tener que entrenarnos
para aprender a colaborar con ellas y es
en esta colaboración donde lo que nos va
a hacer sobrevivir como humanos es
aquello en lo que somos más humanos es
el factor humanista el que nos va a
permitir hacerlo este impacto y esta
posibilidad no requiere cambiar la forma
en que educamos y entrenamos para el
trabajo la forma en que definimos los
roles y los empleos pero especialmente
la forma en que educamos a las nuevas
generaciones mi apuesta personal es por
nuestras niñas porque hoy competimos en
un mundo global
hoy competimos en un mundo global si hoy
no les enseñamos a amar aprender a amar
usar tecnologías para solucionar
problemas pero adicionalmente a sentirse
capaces de intervenir en el futuro y en
las realidades de su entorno inmediato
las estamos dejando atrás es por esto
que yo tuve grandes experiencias y las
he tenido si yo tuviera que darles tres
consejos de aquello que me ha permitido
tener una vida de la cual día a día me
siento orgullosa les invitaría a cada
una a hacerse tres preguntas y luego un
reto primero que están haciendo hoy cada
día por construir la familia la
comunidad y el país con el que sueñan la
segunda pregunta cómo están aprendiendo
cosas nuevas como nos están quedando
atrás del lo que está sucediendo y
finalmente qué tan capaces y preparados
están cada uno de ustedes para adaptarse
a estas nuevas realidades hago una
aclaración
ese día de esa última imagen yo era un
avatar estaba llamando a mi esposo por
videoconferencia de whatsapp
primero lo sorprendió mucho pero esa es
la realidad en la que estamos empezando
a vivir no tenemos que perder la
capacidad de sorprendernos pero sí la de
adaptarnos así es que yo he tenido esta
este empujón enorme que me ha permitido
no necesariamente y ya como notarán la
ruta cambio no ser presidente no tener
un cargo para tener el impacto pero no
perder el objetivo diario de impactar a
estas comunidades quiero otra vez
invitarlos a que abran su celular si
tuvieran un superpoder que les
permitiera a cada uno de ustedes
solucionar un problema por donde
comenzarían en los próximos 30 días y
les invito a hacer ese compromiso
público de la misma manera
me puedo volver
esta dirección es nueva lo pueden
escribir también después pero los invito
porque siempre que uno rinde cuentas
frente a otros frente a los que los
rodean de aquello que sueña es más fácil
llegar allá muchas gracias
[Aplausos]